did you all have a nice Christmas
wonderful yeah
that was your best time hey I got an
instant pot you know what an instant pot
no I don't I made a vow to learn how to
cook my own meals and an instapot is an
electronic device uh that you can do
things like put in a loaf of bread some
ground beef a bucket of water and 20
minutes later you have steak and kidney
pot
it's delicious isn't America it is we're
way ahead of you people in many ways we
really are now at Marty you know people
go to parties on YouTube do you avoid a
dance floor or do you go out and just
show off and go to watch this no no I I
avoid it I love to watch people dancing
really it's the most entertaining thing
on the planet and the more alcohol comes
in the better it gets so I really love
that and after I have a few drinks I
dance but I I never dance like yeah yeah
drink up mozzie
yeah now what's weird is I I assumed
that Matthew Matthew Reese you would be
drinking the wine because you are a wine
expert yes I tell everyone I am a wine
expert do you know this he is a wine
expert I didn't even tell you that but I
am I am officially one of wales's
greatest leading authorities on wine
yeah how many wine experts are there in
Wales actually two two
well I try and host a show called them
called the wine ironically called the
wine show which with with Matthew good
look there he is Dashing Matthew good
and he very kindly called me up one day
he said look do you want to do you want
to travel around Italy with a wine
master and he'll tell us everything
about wine
um they just need two monkeys who you
know who love wine but know nothing
about it to be informed and I was one of
those but there's not much of a spittoon
involved you do just go for it well
Italy was tricky because apparently I
don't even know if this is true but the
Italians told us unlike France where the
when tasting wine they spit the Italians
insist that you take two long drafts the
first should clear the pallet and the
second you taste the wine so buy about 9
30 a.m
yes the producers saying stop saying
it's nice
oh I buy this at Christmas you like say
something else
I got paid I'm so jealous
that's a trip I want to book welcome on
the next series hey now Florence Pugh
you're having a special New Year's Eve
because you like someone on the couch oh
oh I know I do I mean I like all of you
on the couch
no I I particularly love the sound of
Tom Hanks voice oh my really yeah
hey that's great
no my mom actually reminded me this
morning she found out that you were here
and um she said do you remember because
I was sick quite a lot as a kid and I
was always in hospital and they were
always trying to find a good position
for me to sleep in and um apparently I
would always wake up when Toy Story was
over and the ending credits would play
so she'd quickly get up from her bed and
Rewind it and press play again oh so I'm
I've been very soon well you know what
sleep you got a friend
now
[Applause]
[Music]